erakat dit on va faire une review
bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
là je suis bien content de voir baffie
devoir vous je suis me tue bien quand
vous vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi bernard le seul
moment où je me regarde dans la glace
moment où je me rase et franchement je
me parle pas dans ce moment là t'as que
le samedi dans la journée
d'accord dans la journée savary
champagnole tous je vous le dis allez
vas-y mon gars n'auront pas vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petit bernard bas comme tout le monde ça
dépend de l'âge à quel âge pas vers 12
ans là quand on commence à 12 ans 12 ans
mel ferrer mail ferrari parce qu'il
sautait audrey hepburn j'étais fidèle ça
se comprend notre plus belle histoire
d'amour
bah c'est la seule avec ma femme ça fait
32 dans quel but c'est beau 32 ans est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont perdu
un peu le sens du couple quoi c'est la
première difficulté divorce quoi c'est
vrai oui mais il ya des couples c'est
vraiment un coup de bol parce que
tu vois bien il ya des gens pleins de
bonne volonté on va pas se forcer quoi
c'est pas quelque chose qui peut jamais
mais ça peut vouloir la vérité cela il
faut quand même le vous voilà il faut
dire je veux réussir et il ya des
passages difficiles et souvent on
s'aperçoit que si tu sur mon fils il en
y mettant un peu du sien obtus repas
voilà nous on a été vraiment vachement
bien pendant vingt ans sans aucun
problème puis on a commencé à rentrer
dans l'habitude et la turne a eu sauf un
et sophie nous a redonné un coup
incroyable parce qu'on s'est retrouvé
nombre aux parents avec les problèmes
d'un enfant en bas âge et c est là tout
va bien
ah ouais super est ce que vous seriez
prêt à tout quitter pour le pantalon sur
deux mains dans la rue vous tombez sur
une base s mais fou d'amour je la mère
de ma femme j'ai tout à fait j'ai arrêté
de bosser un kit à lire quand on s'est
connus on a arrêté l'un et l'autre de
bosser on a vécu son lot économies et on
a vécu neuf mois rien fait d'autre rien
d'autre que manger dormir et tagada
tsoin après y ait plus de thunes lille
rennes qu'on bosse quand est-ce que vous
avez pleuré pour la dernière fois à
berlin
quand j'ai vu dans ma loge avait pas les
30000 euros promis dans un trou c'est un
jeu n'était pas j'ai chialé on l'a fait
football mais tu n'en veux pas vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
ma date de naissance ouais ah ouais
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous et tu crois pas qu'il
en est et si dit comme ça sans moi j'ai
été gâté on m'a retiré on m'a privé de
mes droits civiques
on m'a privé mais droit parental on m'a
interdit de sport on m'a interdit de
politique on m'interdit d'affaires on
m'a dit vas tu mens réfectoire un
authentique
ils ont cru que j'allais d'ailleurs par
me refaire jamais il y avait un moment
vous êtes dit je vais jamais y arriver à
me refaire away plusieurs fois 1
et justement si vous deviez était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez le
sexe ah ouais bah oui j'ai connu mec
maintenant j'aimerai connaitre pas
tu as envie de te rattraper dont vous
seriez vous soyez un peu et fait c'est
fait c'est pour ça que je te dise à
guéret vous le plus envie d'épater dans
la vie ah c'est un truc que j'ai jamais
aimé ça hein j'ai jamais aimé et pathé o
bernard jeu donner deux exemples
j'avais un beau bateau jamais personne
n'a pu monter dessus voir une photo de
l'intérieur de mon bateau on n'était
jamais ailleurs que loin
il a été acheté par une femme
on a vu la chambre à coucher la salle à
manger un lady des lésés par le podium
sur l'arrière c'est ça épate et c'est à
dire non moi je ne sais pas c'est pas
j'aime bien
j'aime bien surprendre j'aime bien être
et mais j'aime bien ça mais j'aime pas
épaté alors deuxième exemple bateau
c'était le premier c'est quoi le
deuxième exemple dont la maison n'a
qu'une personne est rentré faire des
photos dans nos métiers les chiens 8e il
n'a pas fait de photos il a piqué les
meubles qu'est ce que vous feriez si
vous restez 24 heures à vivre à crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même juste
avant de partir et d'aller voir un il y
en a quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés
encore et encore de 3 bourre pif dans
l'air et ouais ya 2-3 une tournée à
faire est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé au
suicide
oui une fois en prison non non non
c'était dehors et grâce à la à la
présence d'esprit ma femme ça c'est ça
c'est parfait qu'est ce que la vie vous
a appris bernard tapie qui le pire n'est
jamais certain
oui comment aimeriez-vous mourir bonjour
enterré incinérés un vrai qu'on
l'enterré vivant comme en descente le
nom alors je pense que sagement complète
j'ai pas peur de ça du touch croyants
j'ai pas fait trop de mal
mais contrairement à ce qu'on a dit a
pas tellement de gens qui ont souffert
et donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'il me dire allez bien il était temps
que tu arrives et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou